hello everyone I hope you all had an
excellent weekend now this next game
comes as a suggestion from a subscriber
Emmanuel Bonamici and I decided to add a
print screen of this suggestion as it's
quite a long suggestion so I do hope you
really enjoyed this game as it's one of
the one of the weirder games you'll ever
see and I kind of yeah you'll see what I
mean by the title and the move the move
played really I mean it probably does
fit in the in the line of the fringe
that was played but even on chess
games.com official official page
grandmaster raymond keen also states
that this move kinda kind of only serves
the purpose to to enrage the beast that
is Kasparov but you'll see what I mean
by this the game is played in 1995 in
Horgan Switzerland and it's a
round-robin of that ten of the ten of
the highest rated players of that time
but I will I will show you who the
players were and the final standings
after I show you this game so let's see
it it's Garry Kasparov with the white
piece against vasily von Schuch and I do
owe you a vastly one shoot game as it
was his birthday and I didn't show any
game by imagicon his birthday so a
sparrow opens would be four we have e
six D four we have D five so at the
French defense and Knight to c3 Bishop
to b4 the V number variation we have E 5
the advanced variation and here probably
90% of the time when you play e5 against
someone they will probably respond with
c5 and then you can go a3 and they can
decide whether they want to capture the
knight or or maybe go back with the
bishop but in this game are very
interesting variation so maybe those who
enjoyed the French I'm not one of those
people can see what happens if black
decides to play b6 as part of continued
the regular a3 and this is the move that
that titles this video here you probably
want to play Bishop captors on c3 that's
basically the whole idea another thing
you could do is play Bishop him back to
e7 maybe you don't want to capture maybe
you want
leave the game in a different direction
but here if I don't replace a bishop all
the way to f8 and this is what what even
a grandmaster a máquina
says that this is this is a move that is
made to who to enrage Kasparov so
Kasparov continues nice to f3
we have knife to e7 so now you can see
that if you retreat it with the Bishop
to e7 you would kind of have to figure
out how to develop this Knight and
definitely not like this cuz power plays
h4 he wants to meet Knight g6 with h5 so
that's blacks position is gonna be a bit
cramped
due to this weird formation in von
Schuch is playing we have h 6 and now h5
not even allowing knight to come to g6
to g6 a5 Bishop to b5 check he went two
blocks with c6 and this is a move where
Caspar probably did get a little bit
enraged by that silly restricting once
you've made and by the move Bishop to f8
I hear you want to go back but to d3 or
Bishop to e2 because later eventually
we'll use this massive punch in to
harass this Bishop and expand on the
Queen side Bishop to a four by Kasparov
we have Knight to d7 nice to e2 we have
b5 now kicking the bishop black Bishop
to b3 and now c5 so you can see you want
to created this massive pawn chain on
the Queen side
rc3 making some room for the bishop and
c2 Knight to c6
we have castles by Kasparov and the
Queen to c7 and although if on ships the
pieces are well they are pretty much
undeveloped the bishops are still in the
starting squares the rooks are also on
the starting squares the the Queen and
two nights are developed but they're not
really doing anything but still because
he won she does have this massive pawn
chain on the Queen side he does have a
lot of a lot of resources he can use he
can push this he can pull this input
this he can capture here so a lot of
ideas for even took rook to e1 rook to
e1 is a move that
Grandmaster Raymond King thinks that
it's it's a waste of time he suggests
that may be nice to H
followed by f4 in the immediate f5 would
be better but actually the engine agrees
with Kasparov at the engine considers
rook to e1 the available available move
for white so c4 Bishop to c2 and now
Knight the b6 we have Bishop to f4
Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to d3 rook
to b8 you could have you could even push
before immediately but he mantra doesn't
want to exchange rooks so first he will
prepare before rook to b8 we have nice
to h2 now Kasparov will prepare f4 and
here again you can push b4 here you can
go Knight to a4 maybe pressure that be
to pawn either force cost part of the
defendant or maybe give up this very
strong light square bishop but even took
place Queen to d8 and Queen to d8 is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
as you can see this Bishop on g3 is
x-raying the Queen and c7 also there's a
rock on b8 behind the Queen so you don't
want to keep this here when the position
opens up so Queen to d8 we have Knight
to g4 and now before it captures a
captures and here we have C capture Sun
before I'd captured some before and now
Bishop to B 1 and here you want to place
Bishop to d7 Bishop to d7 is a move that
that avoids the threat of Knight to f6
for example if you castle here
immediately we get a nice to have six
check and then you can't capture the
night you have to move the King and then
the queen is coming into the game
because if you capture the night then
you get pawn captures and now the bishop
is attacked and also the rook on b8 is
undefended and if you try to stop
everything then you get Bishop to d6
which kind of does seem like you keep
the piece and defend everything but the
Bishop captures Queen kept percent Queen
to c1 and there is no defense for black
here you can't stop Queen captures on h6
followed by Queen g7 checkmate there's
no more black and played to prevent this
so after Bishop to be won Bishop to d7
developing the bishop and now the queen
is also guarding the rook so nice to
have six will not be a problem in the
future
b3 but as part of we have rook to e8
rook captures Queen captures and now B
captures on c4 Knight captures on c4 and
now tonight the c1 a preparing Tori
maneuver the night
maybe maybe 2 B 3 to guard the d4 pawn
maybe maybe even to c5 later but here
you will see how well how well place the
even chokes Knights are now here Bishop
to a for attacking Kasparov's Queen
Queen to e2 and now Queen to a7 and now
if you look at this position you can see
that the pawn on d4 is attacked and even
though Kasparov has so many pieces
surrounding this d4 pawn there is no
move he can make to actually defend the
pawn so here Kasparov tried knife to e3
but he went to simply grab the pawn so
Queen captures on d4 we have night
captors on c4 pawn captures and now
Queen to f1 there's really there's
really not much you can do here as white
as power played Queen to f1 probably
because he already given up on the game
he went look castled and here we want to
castle and move 31 and it was in this
position that garry kasparov resigned
the game so yeah i mean quite a game and
quite quite some choices he went took
made to develop his pieces and it
definitely definitely did have some sort
of a psychological effect on Kasparov as
he already he already played that poor
maneuver with the Bishop Hill out divine
Chuck to really expand on the Queen side
and he couldn't he couldn't find a way
to tackle this variation you want to
play so maybe if you if you play the
French maybe if you you know encounter
this advanced variation of the V number
and maybe you can try this b6 Bishop to
a fate idea yeah if it worked for
revenge against Casper oh maybe it will
work for you and I did promise the final
standings so here they are you have even
shook in first place he won the
tournament with 7 points along with
Vladimir Kramnik
then you have Elvis short Kasparov
Google Coronel you super low tier Vogon
Ian and demon in last place so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank dorable farinelli
Joshua Murphy Vijay Kumar Krishna Sami
Garrett Beasley and the Donald
Pettingill for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video maybe maybe even the
one where Nigel short lost the game I
believe it was yesterday because he
forgot to press the clock he had a
winning position he just forgot to press
the clock and he lost some time so yeah
once again thank you for watching and I
will see you soon